the jonas brothers joined forces with
marshmallow to close out the 2021
billboard music awards on sunday
taking the stage at the microsoft
theater in los angeles
the group delivered an unforgettable
performance of their new single
leave before you love me
[Music]
nick jonas who hosted the big night and
his brothers
joe and kevin then turned it up a notch
belting out classic hits like
sucker
[Applause]
and lit up the stage for what a man
gotta do
their spectacular performance comes
after the jobros announced their
remember this tour coming this summer
with special guest
kelsey ballerini let's go on top yeah
let's go on tour
let's do that and if that thing just
happened since i was like 13
so it feels like it's not wait we'll see
you in a few months
e.t spoke with nick ahead of the big
night where he talked
more about what the band has in the
works this could mean that there will be
new jonas brothers music
we've been you know working together in
this year and a half where we've been
apart
and and you know always kind of keeping
on the grind a little bit
and trying to find new new songs and and
new inspiration and
you know i think with the tour in mind
it would make sense but i don't again i
don't want to give too much away
just keep your eyes okay how's the
dynamic changed
because you are all married how
different is it
it's definitely different but i think
it's just gotten better uh you know
in a way i think we were we're all so
much a part of each other's lives
outside of the work that we did which is
just natural for family but to to be
able to
to kind of go home to separate lives
where you can
you know kind of just work through
different things on your own with your
person
and kind of have your own setup within
your family set up
is so important and it just makes all of
us i think
better men better musicians and artists
and and
honestly better brothers to each other
speaking of married life
nick was also burning up on the red
carpet with his wife priyanka chopra
jonas opted for a full emerald green
fendi ensemble
completing his look with a gold chain
and black boots
while the actress looked gorgeous in
gold dolce and cabana
before their big date night nick told et
that he didn't know if his wife could
make it
she's been back and forth to the uk
shooting a new
show there which is going to be
incredible but hopefully fingers crossed
she can
she can come and support it's safe to
say priyanka showed up for her man which
makes them our couple's goals for the
night